the national poll is barely a month away
but opposition parties right activists
and political analysts are saying the
situation in Bangladesh is not conducive
for
elections the issue right now is not
just the feud between two main political
parties or their leaders but citizens
right to vote which has been eroding
since 2014 election and if once again
people are deprived of their right to
vote they will not take it
lightly one lawyer's Forum estimates
more than 20,000 opposition leaders
activists and supporters have been
arrested since late
October if there are any clashes or
public disorder related to the election
the responsibility lies with the
election commission we have full
confidence in it whatever decision it
takes last week the chief election
commissioner said that Bangladesh is now
in crisis citing the general election to
be held on January 7 and saying there's
been external influence on the election
process despite this some people are
hopeful as of now I can't say for sure
whether it will be a fair election or
not until and unless we can go to the
polling centers only then will we know
opposition parties and rights groups say
the governing Army league is trying to
consolidate its gripe on power in the
run up to vote by suppressing descent T
trre Al jazer Dhaka